you
64 was that magic number downbeat is the
guy who got it or girl we'll see all
right so English but we're not quite
sure who are not quite sure what this
will turn into hmm if I play this we're
going to enter nims Oh Indian land let's
I'm open to it d5 Queens gambit declined
Bishop b4 nims Oh Indian ok so Queens
gambit declined so let me go with this
and try for what exactly I want to try
to well I have a couple plans I could go
forward with one is the minority attack
and let me make sure that I don't give
black and easy time with developing
their light squared Bishop so that's why
it's Queen see to first and then I'll
play III Bishop here if I'm going to go
forward with a central expansion that's
the other plan minority attack which is
to get this pawn up to be five the other
thing is central expansion which means
the bishop belongs on d3 in this night
not to its classical square f3 strop
back I'm not so quick to give up my
bishop I don't know if that there's a
great difference between these two
squares now maybe there is actually if i
go to f4 night here and then there would
be a night for Bishop exchange
potentially and probably but ok if the
night moves we're going to have the dark
square Bishop scum off which I is which
I is there's some wonderful grammar for
you which is quite alright for me
because my resulting pawn structure is
on dark and it complements my remaining
light
square Bishop very well so one move away
from being fully developed do I have
some other options first quick second I
thought about this g5 I could take that
but I don't I don't really care about
going after that Bishop just yet let me
make sure I get developed castleman's
Bishop is a little bit short on squares
doing something outlandish like f4 f5
trying to trap this I don't know about
that weakens this considerably in fact
after F for this night could drop back
ok let's not do that so should I still
continue with this idea of the central
expansion I have enough support on d4
which is important because after this
pond makes a capture this Queen could be
putting pressure on it so can I go right
for f3 and this I'm going to give it a
shot and with my bishop now on h4 if
it's challenged if let's say the night
moves to h5 I could drop all the way
back to f2 which is quite helpful in the
with supporting d4 so how how should
black be responding what would you do if
you were playing as team black have all
the minor pieces out castled should the
Queen come out somewhere is coming out
in this direction a good idea alright
night each five it is no thank you and
avoid that placing a bishop or not oh ok
well this looks to prevent a pond duo d
for e for structure that's a quite
interesting move but I might still say
let's uh let's go do soon there's some
loose pieces here you know what I could
try to do you could try to be sneaky
now what am I talking about I could take
that bucket I could take that pot I
trusted my opponent right there you see
that you hear it I trusted my opponent
that's a free pun tak twice defendant
once this is what I was going to do I
was going to be sneaky play Queen I was
trying to be fancy queen bee three
hitting this in pinning this pond with e
for to follow but that is a free pun
look right in front of you look right in
front of you okay so that really wasn't
defending against efore but I trusted my
opponent there you heard it and now I'm
hitting the night and I have some
checking opportunities my queen is she
can't be dislodged so easily so I'm
gonna I'm gonna follow through so it's
the same thing I'm able to get in this
efore advance but now under much more
favorable circumstances of course with
the material edge and if there isn't
this capture well I'll regardless being
able to maintain or just get this
structure in means that I will be able
to get into e5 and push my opponent
around in the most are the best
defensive square for this King side
position the knight on f6 in particular
will have to find a new home this night
is ready to jump in and do some damage
on these light squares and that's an
interesting idea so getting ready to
jump in here maybe I do well to do well
to do what hmm
maybe play night here now let's try that
gemini 10 i think my opponent will offer
queen trade and I'm I'm okay with it but
maybe maybe I'm really wanting to get
something more out of it since I'm I
feel that it's my opponent's king who's
more vulnerable having this structure
with light squares and a piece already
could be jumping in there I find that as
a good thing right here I could pick up
the bishop but I don't know how great
that is I have my Center covered enough
as soon as I do this the Knights make
use of d5 do I really want to allow that
mmm oh let me pin this
yeah let me get oh yeah and give this
pot up let me get a rook working finally
my queen is still in blacks territory
that can't the black can't be
comfortable like that and I could play
Bishop here I don't need the support on
this square i also want to just get rid
of this night i think getting rid of
this night means that my opponents
position will crumble very quickly i
could have also considered bishop g3 for
some discovered tricks on the queen but
i think the the primary glue here for
black is this night on f7 once I
overtake the f6 square my queen and rook
are directly or indirectly having
prospects on the f7 and f eight squares
have all my pieces working my center is
covered he's out of play for as long as
I keep my pawn on e4 sitting he's very
tempting i must say to just want to do
this particular move and now there's
going to be some serious problems
because there's an ensuing discovered
check so if night here i take the Queen
and now i take the night with check so
this is netting a full piece actually
more than that i'm not going to take the
night there's a fork to follow so this
is a serious material disadvantage and
i'm not going to just as I would not
capture a pinned piece I am NOT going to
capture either one of those rooks okay
my poner designed good game this is just
this last position it's a good idea to
just keep this as is and not take a ruck
until one of them moves black as a
result will just be wasting a move all
right good game let's flip this in see
if we could take something away from it
my initial thought is well keep in mind
that if you're wanting to eliminate
White's potential plan of a central
expansion
you it let me let me back up for a
second if your main intention is to
really go forward with the Queens gambit
declined and not the names Oh Indian
which you do have the opportunity to
play right now I think you can enter the
Queens gambit declined under more
favorable circumstances which is to say
at this point right here don't play your
night out but just play d5 right away
but then again maybe maybe it allows me
some different opportunities maybe I
don't have to plant my pawn on d4 the
point I'm getting at is that with the
knight on f6 with the King night
developed prior to the bishop I do have
Bishop g5 and I'm able to have this
central expansion available you'll note
right here if it followed D 5 D for
Bishop e7 then I don't have the bishop
coming out to g5 I'd have to do
something like Knight f3 which means
that I can't go forward with the central
expansion or if I'm playing III well
then you don't have to worry about my
bishop coming out there's a main
difference between Knight f6 and Bishop
e7 and it involves eliminating one of
whites middle game plans this is the
first one that struck me is a little bit
odd here's and here's another thing that
you could go for is black you can go
forward with not castling here and the
reason behind that is to make use of
this f8 square with your queen night you
could go nite d7 to f8 it's a very long
process but this this maneuver that I'm
about to express is is played in order
to trade off light square bishops my
bishop will be on d3 and so you can go
forward with night d 7 f 8 e 6 with a
tempo and the bishop and so we're seeing
as a result a reason to not play h6
d7 f-86 with the temple on the bishop
the bishop backs up g6 again this is
very long-winded night g7 followed by
Bishop to f5 I'm knotted to use some
analysis feature on here but if you
could follow that the night's journey to
knock castle make use of F 897 f-86 g6
the night that's on now in e6 comes to
g7 and finally Bishop here now of course
why could be doing many things in the
meantime but I believe that black will
be successful in at least exchanging off
those LightSquared bishops which is
exactly what you would want since you
have pawns fixed on light squares anyhow
that's a that's an approach you could
have been taking it was not the road you
went down and this actually turns out to
play into my hands if you really did
want to force this dark square Bishop
exchange you should do so prior to you
should do so prior to my playing f3
because this is a convenient reply that
I have after I have f3 inserted I avoid
the exchanges a while I don't have a
space advantage in this position just
yet I'm viewing it as is as if I do
because I can get this efore move in
successfully and I'm then just one step
away from entering your territory and
claiming that space advantage and so
that's a reason for me to avoid this
particular exchange since i'm i'm
anticipating i will have a space
advantage and this is the beginning of
the end really there's no turning back
at this point after the material edge i
don't believe i gave you an opportunity
to sneak away and I don't it's it's
difficult to really suggest something
for you the best one one way that you
could be meeting a central expansion
like this is to strike at my d4 pawn
with c5 so that's the other move to be
looking into if you're not going to do
this move then d 4 is going to be very
well secure and I won't have any
problems with getting this advanced in
may be right away or by first getting
another piece involved but I
I like being able to do this move right
away I have five as we saw was a blunder
and the reasons that I was expressing I
was hesitant to make this particular
move it looks appealing maybe it's maybe
it's good further back it that is to say
but I didn't want to give up that d 5
square but this turned out to be a
blender the Queen f7 move and lastly
don't take one of those rooks until one
of these rooks moves until your hand is
forced okay good game
you